Joe we've already asked you about your
virtual wedding reactions Maisy what was
your reaction to the red wedding I did a
vine I made a vine I can't actually
watch the episode I heard it come out
and I was on Twitter and everyone was
going vine it's like a video thing wait
for you're pressing the screen it
records as well as doing a min ago okay
sorry I had but everyone's going crazy
on Twitter so I thought I'd do a little
reaction and then I actually watched the
episode afterwards it was kind of like
oh that was really unsympathetic because
it was really sad now obviously we've
lost shed loads of people on the show so
far it's sad to see anyone go but of the
deaths that they've been who do you
think stands out the most I think I was
quite sad when Viceroy's died in episode
a like right at the beginning just
because he was a really good buddy and I
think at the time people were kind of
like oh yeah it's good that a bad guy
said but then when all the good guy
started to die they were like hey maybe
we you know that was better than we
thought it was going to be interesting
character that we thought people were
thinking maybe this was pretty
interesting yeah I think for a personal
point of view la means was horrible yeah
we obviously spent months and months
working with our us and then he was cut
because it is like that on the show when
someone someone dead on the show then
you don't see them for ages if ever
again if you could bring anybody back
who would it mean I know obviously I has
tried to bring Ned back with varrick so
anyone apart from nerds
[Music]
no one I hate your mom now I'm doing I'm
taking action and character-wise
I think Oh who's who's the guy that that
you got Jack and to kill in season two
looking for a bastard named Gendry Oh
Amory Lorch just cuz I love the way he
said that really cuts it I'm never gonna
hear
you